so from a military perspective this ICC
announcement does it change anything
ultimately depends how Putin responds to
it but if we look one year on into
Putin's special military operation it
looks likely his objectives were Crimea
to the South and Don bass to the east
has been Fierce fighting in Don bass
because he's still trying to take the
bit he doesn't own but it does look like
that Russian offensive is stalling
Russia desperately needs more soldiers
but particularly more equipment as well
and most military families that would
take time most military analysts think
he's coming up to a point where he's got
choices one of those choices was the to
pursue peace talks because if it was to
do that he would probably stop Ukraine
mounting their spring offensive it will
buy him time potentially give him an off
ramp and also it sounds like China's
positioning itself to be some sort of
broker for peace as well the other
alternative Putin is just to keep
grinding on with this war with massive
more casualties now Russia doesn't
respect the international criminal court
but it will make it more difficult for
Putin to travel around and if he was
inclined to start engaging in peace
talks the danger is that brings the end
of the conflict closer which actually is
probably at the moment not what
President Putin wants so I suspect that
this decision is almost certainly going
to prolong and cause President Putin
just to stiffen his resolve what role do
these International institutions like
the ICC like the UN what role do they
have to play can they take meaningful
action no really but um there's a little
talk yesterday that Russia should be
expelled from United Nations but I think
that and that that could happen they
have limited teeth uh the G7 the G20 all
these but their aim is actually to
create an environment in which countries
that not generally aligned can at least
talk and negotiate and find a way of
easing tensions to try and stop them
ending up uh concluding in Acts of War
so notwithstanding what President
Putin's illegal invasion of Ukraine
there are many who would argue that
that's not justification for expelling
out of the UN because that could be
counterproductive in the longer term
from a western perspective I think the
decision to indict Putin looks like a
major event and significant development
but from Putin's perspective he's almost
certainly sees this as as a minor speed
bump and we're not going to see him in
court anytime soon we have seen him
today though haven't we because it's the
ninth anniversary of the illegal
annexation of Crimea and he's visited
the region yes he does like to celebrate
um the visits to um to these
anniversaries and normally they
celebrate with some sort of concert or
some sort of rally
um apparently today in Crimea there was
a youth rally there were some big
banners being waived that says Russia
doesn't start wars it ends them which is
a slight irony based on the facts but
it's also Russia took the opportunity
they have managed to reopen the cursed
bridge if you remember that was damaged
it's been open 39 days early
coincidentally on this anniversary uh
Putin it's very important to Putin it's
a link between Russia and Crimea
obviously it was open in 2018 but in
October last year a series of explosions
caused some a lot of damage now it's
back passable to road traffic and that's
important for Russia because this is a
vital or arterial link for Russia's
military Invasion Force into Ukraine